all right three two and action
oh my darling we've been together a long
long time now and I I love you so very
much I love you too
just say you love him back acting like
you love something I love you too
I flutter your eyes flutter flutter hard
it under Adam I'm done
dodo are you gonna get my brother are
you getting up to propose yet Jeff oh no
come back it is I don't know dress what
I have everything I love you my big ogre
brother with his goatee it's just pain
oh oh come on it could be could be a
girl from dodgeball who had the steroids
and the hairy arm
hey when she was out of her makeup she
was beautiful so don't you criticize
what are we gonna do it again this is my
video you're gonna be because you come
on the dress damn it
Oh God okay fine fine first okay fine
we're done